he is a fan favorite and multiple-time
wal champion considered by many to be
the best ever to pull and a future
hall-of-famer is no limits
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go Devon's got position is
he'll explain yeah Wow Jodie says it's
what Devon thinks it's over
[Applause]
Wow this is absolutely impressive
my goodness
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my goodness he's holding Jerry cataract
a dead center vote congeries power this
is a
and he's going to work here back he's
making micro adjustments maybe you don't
see it but he's making micro adjustments
every every time Kari takes a breath
definite blues position by looking at ya
higher and higher and more and more
better with every breath Gary takes
[Applause]
[Music]
just the lower these terrible war
this is career-ending
[Applause]
now it's about power now it's about
top-end
Dever trying to beat him a pure power I
love
[Applause]
push it yeah push it off the side of the
table bet this is straight side to side
forget the technique who's stronger
right that's all it's a boost our right
now
no it's looking like Jerry's got that
Devin's wearing him
right now - what we need for devil Aaron
Wow my goodness 5 3 2 2
the sex match of the night and that was
an absolute war Wow that was the match
of the night close your hands
[Applause]
I'm speechless just watching this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
bastards up Vasquez's hand again does
he's waiting he's waiting is waiting or
does he
[Applause]
and ever told the match ball bats
waiting
getting it back into the middle
[Applause]
not over yet close your hands go Merritt
trying to win
Gemini's position that's waiting
yes observant Devon's got his hand
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just staring him down
[Applause]
[Music]
davin lair wins it 3-1 portal his body
will react - no - decide he's taking the
rest of luck tell you what it is
anybody who doubts into Michael Turner's
win this match don't know longer because
Devin is gonna have to work with it's
one big time Michael Tuohy hanging back
Michael can stay there for a long long
time I see gen Meade stick Gainey's he
needs to walk and no fit wrong with
those elbows there's the drive the
attempted crime he's going to take small
bite-sized moves to try to gain
he can't eat big sweets he could reach
anywhere on the table but he must time
the movie for any extended period of
time
[Applause]
super cerebral
[Applause]
[Music]
readings that's the benefit he's got
rhythm
[Applause]
wrist control he's feeling around she's
trying to see deacon disturbing the arm
of my culture
the opinion that nobody has the
endurance and Devon are about to find
out
there's exactly the same as we saw in
in Manchester I'm gonna try and press
[Applause]
are you kidding me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just watch the box - 45 maybe 30 40
pounds
[Applause]
[Music]
Devon sets him in a deeper
[Applause]
Tappin
[Applause]
[Music]
human look at that in any other with
this leverage in this position you would
easily finish your poem
[Applause]
you saw the transition day Vemma
leverage gaining the hand control
getting it moving along and finishing
with the tugs on the table
[Applause]
he did that's what he won his know was
upset with the Chaffee they're trying to
finish he's not been able to do so there
and this is actually good for Devon in
some respect because he wants that
horsepower to be burned to be diminished
and Chaffey every time he stretches open
like that it's actually good for Aaron
he comes and connects but he can't
finish and leritz staying with it
Larrick putting some bullets into him
now and this is the strategy that he was
looking for early he wants to tired it
to make it a battle of attrition Dave
doesn't do well here he's a dragster
yeah have you looked at the two
it's a dragster against a rally car
right when it's on a straight volleyball
that dragster as the speed right now the
road is a point P well Dave Chaffee is
feeling it now Devon were pitting there
he wants you to pin himself he wants to
embarrass him the tables fallen apart
[Applause]
Darren's got him they're talking about
sportsmanship there and yesterday he
said I'll let you he likes to be in that
situation he likes to create freedom at
the table where he can move where he can
utilize that hand and wrist strategy to
burn his opponent he knows that day HF
is stronger but he also knows that it's
almost boxer against the function knows
that if he can put miles on Dave's
overcome then he has the advantage he
said he's about to do so I think Dave TV
has tried to pull a tipped move he's
dropped right now under the table he's
trying to win this with body weight and
Devin Lara just smile at her Devin
connects in Dave's trying to come up and
engage a press he's going Philippe like
never before but Devin is working very
hard here believe me he's trying to try
and he's trying to bounce stay back
David just get her himself
he needs to watch that over big pressure
there but he's right there is the
sacrifice there the lure
he's baiting it he's talking to him
three fouls and it's again for Devin and
Devin wasn't attacking back there yeah
he was letting Dave feel like he was in
the match he was letting Dave attacked
and burst his energy wide open Davis
very light left now they were mocking
him because he utilized Mike's all move
the arms move up a long horrible affair
safety trying to stay alive huge drive
for an inmate but if you look at Devon's
face all that kind of stuff it on Devon
Springs actually yeah yes to gain
position yep and that's not
intentionally stood to gain a Devon
talking to watch intentionally there he
didn't allow deaden the opportunity to
pin him he looked for the way out
unfold himself out of the match yeah
[Applause]
from Lara he's got the horse already
stays with it mortal Otto trying to
reconnect with
Chris needs to be patient staying with
it and gather his arm doesn't want to
burn out and this is a bleed now for too
long toys from Brazil he's very familiar
with the Anaconda devil era right now
he'll wait for the mistake he will
squeeze
he will tighten and they'll try to choke
the line
[Applause]
and real team cares was awake so early
they drive in this time mortal Alto
stays a little tighter but look at the
face yes
there's the squeeze now he'll apply of
pressure into Magnus hand at that point
Magna needs to tighten needs to stay
with his arm don't expose the hand and
wrist the leverage the height and length
of the forearm of Devon gives him so
many options and he'll try to make minor
adjustments as the locks Perez's
tsch difference it always been for at
that moon he's moving down doing one
total slash this morning moves down and
trash not a risk of mortality up not
supreme ruler with mortal Otto strength
in the joints
whoa grinding brutal pull 45 seconds of
Saturday rain but you can see there the
fatigue factor that he walks onto any
opponent who faces Devin Lara yep yep
very cool stop time
[Music]
as we expected better yeah he felt
enough from Wagner to think you know
what this isn't a guy I'm gonna give
anymore let's put it away Wiseman
and you never know Devin Levin man just
earned himself a few more pounds because
tonight yato Kingsman